delanoë
bonsoir bonsoir alors ton vrai nom c'est
comment mon nom de naissance et claude
vorilhon peu de vos rayons
alors est ce un tournant d'une certaine
façon elle c'est le nom qui m'a été
donnée par ces êtres de l'espace que
j'ai rencontré les elohim envahi venir
profession de ton père faisait quoi de
père inconnu et amer ma mère
très gentil femmes à la maison oui femme
au foyer femme au foyer
alors tu dit être né de l'insémination
de ta mère par un extra-terrestre oui
j'ai appris ça quand j'avais 22 29 ans
adore de la deuxième rencontre avec ces
êtres de l'espace et c'était un coup de
massue sur la tête au départ et puis
j'ai compris par la suite que c'était
simplement comme c'est arrivé de nous
des milliers de fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité pour prouver que ces êtres de
l'espace sont comme sont des êtres
humains comme nous et si ils font
l'amour avec une femme de la terre ça
fait un enfant alors que si un chien h à
sa coupe ça fait rien du tout donc ils
sont à notre image ils nous ont créé à
leur image et ce qui est écrit dans la
bible mais il n'y a pas de dieu c'est
pas ta mère vous a raconté
non c'est cet être de l'espace que j'ai
rencontré et qui s'appelle i have a
dream est ton adolescence ça s'est passé
comment adolescente j'étais passionné
par jacques brel et j'ai pris mes rejet
oui j'étais fou de jacques brel et j'ai
pris ma guitare je suis monté à paris
j'ai chanté dans les boîtes oui chanter
et j'étais sûr c'est sur sa route et
j'étais saoul passionné devraient se
souvient des chansons de jacques brel
bien sûr tu peux nous en faire une juste
un mois si j'avais ma guitare oui mais
là c'est très dur comme ça avec la mer
du nord pour derniers terrains vagues et
des fades d'une poire et et les vagues
et de zinc au rocher que les marais
dépasse c'est bien ça fait le service
militaire
non non non parce que j'ai tout fait
pour ce qu'il fallait pour me faire
réformer et s'ils savaient pas être
marché j'aurais été objecteurs de
conscience et un intérêt fort mais qui
peut arrêter des conneries maintenant
ton premier métier alors c'était
chanteur c'était oui c'était le chanteur
s'était auteur compositeur a été
journaliste après bah oui j'avais une
autre passion qui était le sport
automobile et j'ai essayé par le
journalisme de d'avoir des voitures de
course c'est à clermont ferrand c'était
à clermont ferrand
et alors c'est là que c'était arrivé
c'est le 13 décembre pour le 113
alors à quand tout ce qui s'est passé
entre 173 je reviens du tour de corse ou
que j'ai couvert comme journaliste et
puis je me lève et je parle est un
volcan qui s'appelle le puits de la cela
qui est juste un 10 km de clermont
ferrand et là j'arrive tu aller vers
ceux vers ce volcan où une force qui
ennuie exactement un peu comme dans le
film rencontre du troisième type je
savais pas pourquoi mais j'avais cette
forme il fallait que j'aille là et je
suis allé d'un à cet endroit là et en
demandant qu'est-ce que je fais là
j'étais dans le volcan j'aime et j'ai du
travail à nos bureaux pourquoi je suis
là et là un engin est apparue quelque
chose comme une cloche un petit peu fait
fait de métal argenté très brillant qui
est descendue doucement sans le moindre
bruit ça avait l'air de poser plusieurs
tonnes ça s'est immobilisé à peu près 30
mètres de moi une trappe s'est ouverte
et un petit être est sorti avec des yeux
très en amont très élevé des morts chez
des bovins s'est approché de moi j'avais
une barbiche tu dis une petite barre
wiimote à visage beaucoup plus proche
des asiatiques que des européens
c'est un quand il a été en face de moi
mais j'ai osé poser une question pour
voir s'ils me comprenez j'étais sûr
qu'il ne comprenait pas et je pose une
question il m'a compris il m'a répondu
en français parfait et là il m'a dit
grâce à une technologie qui l'ont 25000
en avance sur nous ils peuvent parler
toutes les langues du monde et le
message a commencé il a commencé à me
donner le message à savoir qu' il avait
créé la vie sur terre qui avait pas de
dieu que c'était eux qui avaient été
pris pour des dieux et que leur nom
s'était elle rime qu'on trouve dans la
bible et donc la bible est le plus
ancien livre raté du monde en fait
mais ita il n'a pas donné de preuve de
sa de saisie qui t'a pas laissé quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui occupent les
moines y aurait de la vère
cité de désinformation aucune preuve si
ce n'est le message et j'avoue que moi
j'ai été le premier à y adhérer et j'ai
trouvé ça tellement logique parce
qu'avant il y avait quoi il y avait un
bon dieu surnaturel où l'évolution mais
deux étant des théories 1
contrairement à ce qu'on enseigne dans
les écoles c'est bien la théorie de
l'évolution de la théorie de dieu et une
troisième qui arrivent et qui correspond
à ce qu'on fait maintenant créer la vire
laboratoire en main en faisant des
manipulations génétiques
ça me semble être la plus logique est
relatée devenu réel pourquoi parce
qu'ils m'ont dit arrête ton travail et
va de parlement porte ce message des
genres iront au début mais au fur et à
mesure les gens comprendront et
préparons cette ambassade qui est
l'objectif de notre organisation d'un
livre est construit une ambassade mais
ils vont venir
officiellement et là je serai pas tout
seul tout le monde pour aller voir et
alors ils à faire après c'était encore
plus plus étrange parce qu'en 75 en deux
ans plus tard il promène dans le
périgord et là tu es parti en voyage sur
une autre planète ça s'est passé comment
mais ça s'est passé que le même engin
est apparue et là ils m'ont ils m'ont
donné en quelque sorte une récompense
car le premier contact est un test pour
voir si j'allais faire de l'argent avec
ça si j'allais essayer d'exploiter sa si
j'allais et pendant deux ans j'ai été
bien l'épreuve j'ai parlé sans jamais
chercher à faire d'argent
personnellement et ils m'ont donné la
récompense
ils vont emmener sur la planète oui vive
avec cet engin qui est une téléportation
réelles celles-là presse que en quelques
minutes on peut voyager à des distances
inimaginable c'est comment l'intérieur
de ceux de ce vaisseau spatial très
décevant parce que moi je suis passionné
de sport automobile et de pilotage et je
m'attendais à voir comment ça marche
y'a rien n'y a je sais toujours pas
comment ça marche
il ya eu un intérieur fait de métal
argenté le sol effet comme une pierre
précieuse bleus on s'assoit et du ne
bougeait plus je crois qu'ils voulaient
prendre une photo penser un petit
balancement et on est arrivé c'est à
dire que c'est vraiment la téléportation
et ça dure que le temps d'y penser
d'ailleurs combien de temps mettez vous
pour venir de votre planète j'ai demandé
le temps d'y penser
comment ça va je sais pas cette planète
et comment cette planète c'est le
paradis c'est des gens qui ont 25
millions d' avance sur nous donc ils
vivent
il n'y a pas d'argent il n'y a pas de
violence il n'y a pas de chômage ya pas
de les gens font ce qu'ils aiment
s'épanouissent c'est ce que la terre est
en train de connaître doucement c'est ce
que les enfants d'aujourd'hui
connaîtront un jour
parce que l'homme n'est pas fait pour
travailler il est fait pour faire à
réaliser une bonne nouvelle dans les
biens sont l'homme est fait pour faire
travailler mes ordis n'atteint les
robots pour créer pour penser pour
s'épanouir
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font des
manipulations génétiques et ce qu'ils
font il faut il qu'ils s'amusent à créer
la vie alors là bas tu as rencontré tous
les tous les grands prophètes rencontrer
oui jésus mahomet
ce sont des as qui sont parties de la
terre comme les histoires que racontent
qu'ils sont parties de la terre avec eux
et qu'ils maintiennent scientifiquement
vie vous savez qu'en californie il ya
des gens qui se font cryogénisé c'est à
dire on les met dans de l'azoté liquide
très froid pour les conserver bon ils
ont perfectionné cette technique
puisqu'il 125 millions d' avance et on
peut les recréer à travers une méthode
s'appelle de cloning de corps en corps
on les maintient en vie et quand
l'ambassade qu'on veut construire sera
faite ils reviendront officiellement
avec les extraterrestres qui nous ont
créé pour prouver de ce qui fait
témoigner et c'est ce que toutes les
écritures raconte jésus reviendra
mohammed reviendra pour unifier tous les
amis mais il est revenu il a été demandé
de créer une ambassade
c'est accueillir sur terre alors c'est
quoi cette ambassade et une ambassade
qu'on doit construire si possible à
jérusalem est où ils reviendront
officiellement comme partout cet écrit
pour aider l'humanité mais il faut qu'on
fasse le premier pas savoir commencer à
unifier la planète commencé à arrêter de
faire des stupidités des guerres à
s'unifier avoir un gouvernement mondial
a supprimé les armes et à supprimer les
armes atomiques et a commencé à s'unir
dans ce village planétaire où nous
sommes tu penses que quand jésus a
commencé à raconter ses histoires les
gens avaient le même regard sur lui que
sur toi aujourd'hui le même regard et si
les mêmes médias monteur si les mêmes
journaux comme vsd le nouvel observateur
l'écho des savanes qui ont fait des
articles le calomniateur est dégueulasse
sûrement n'y a pas d'autre mot a qu'est
ce qu'ils ont dit non il disait des
saloperies disent comprendre que les
enfants qu'on viole les enfants aucun
n'a envoyé un journaliste pour
m'interviewer aucun envoyé un
journaliste dans les rassemblements
qu'on a ils ont pris des photos dans des
agences de presse et ils écrivent
n'importe quoi qui reprennent de la
loutre et toute la france de lier toute
la france croit compte qu'on drogue et
enfants qu'on organise des partouzes
exemple c'est complètement fou et vous
êtes le bienvenu à nos réunions pour
vérifier de vous même et si on n'aime
pas les gosses on devient comme
donc là tu as fondé l'asse pas une secte
c'est quoi le savez les premiers
chrétiens interpellé une secte par un
jésus disait des choses qui dérangent et
aussi il disait aussi que son père est
dans les cieux et automatiquement l'ars
une secte comme c'est ce qui est arrivé
aux premiers chrétiens les données aux
lions aujourd'hui ça pourrait être dans
d'autres pays désertique psychiatrique
où des camps de rééducation
en france c'est la presse qui nous salit
qui vit des tas d'ordures sur nous qui
fait que des gens par exemple comme le
docteur françois python de roanne est
licenciée de son hôpital parce qu'il est
rien et le ils étaient combien de
raëliens aujourd'hui dans le monde
il y en a trente mille est ce que ça
coûte cher d'être des tra et bien ça
coûte rien je vais aller je dis qu'il
faut donner 3 7 % de son revenu annuel à
toi on peut deviner qu'on peut devenir
un lien immédiatement et c'est gratuit
maintenant ceux qui veulent peuvent
s'abonner à des revues peuvent devenir
membres actifs et là il verse 3 % de
leurs revenus s'ils ont rien ça fait pas
grand chose c'est ce qu'ils veulent
devenir parmi les responsables ces 7 %
de leurs revenus s'ils ont rien ça fait
pas grand chose non plus c'est la
liberté c'est pas moi le mouvement
réalise ne me verse aucun salaire
comment je vois alors des droits
d'auteur des livres que j'écris pas
celui-là c'est dan et châtiment des
costumes mais c'est vrai que le siège
est en suisse quand même le siège du
mouvement international est en suisse
qui regroupe qui associe les différents
pays un peu comme le vatican
une nuit les églises du monde le vatican
s'est pas en suisse parce qu'en suisse
et les banques suisses oui le péché d'y
penser quand même le vatican et les
bancs du vatican haussier qui sont pas
mal non plus faire alors cet argent est
utilisé pour quoi faire si toi tu en
prends pas de l'argent est accumulée
dans l'objectif de construire cette
ambassade mais c'est cher le terrain
jérusalem non très cher en mars 93 euros
au mur des lamentations
tu as été proclamé nouveau messie des
juifs ça veut dire quoi ça mais s'agit
mais si ça vient de messages et c'est
juste un message j'apporte un message et
le messager n'est pas important ce qui
est important c'est le message c'est que
les gens prennent connaissance ils
peuvent le faire et vérifier c'est ce
que disent les journalistes est vrai ou
pas 36 14 qu'audrey y regarde à toi
aussi tu as
ils regardent et là il ya la vérité qui
doit vérifier par eux-mêmes et avec le
fils comment ça se passe c'est aussi ça
va très bien puisque moi j'habite en
france
ouais c'est pour ça tu habites pas
enfants non mais je veux dire je voyage
autour du monde donc j'ai aucun problème
si je passais plus est des impôts
voyageant au tour du monde j'en paye nul
pas tes rapports étaient concurrents ou
comment ça se passe avec la secte moon
les enfants de dieu enfin toutes ces
scènes
c'est pas une concurrence puisque moi
mon organisation digne a pas de dieu on
a été créé en laboratoire il n'ya pas de
dieu tu te crois seulement dans 20 ans
et guéri
j'espère quoi j'espère être encore aussi
malade que je me suis maintenant et si
des extraterrestres viennent pas tu vas
voir leur faim comme maintenant ils vont
se dire tu es sur asus il n'y a pas de
doute mais quelle heure là parce que
entre maintenant et 2035 ça ben oui
c'est la date ni pourquoi je ne suis
qu'un message et je transmets six cordes
et on sera là avant 2003 entre
maintenant et 2035
je crois qu'on le verra pas si c'est un
ordi je peux pas moi
tu es marié oui tu as des enfants oui
ils sont réels et oui
ah bon quel âge ils ont ma fille a 22
ans et monfils a 21 ans et ils sont n'y
a pas de problème
tout à fait c'est pas faux de faire
plaisir je fais donc pas ce que j'ai sur
libre de l'est où ils veulent
je vais laisser mes enfants entrée libre
si c'était à refaire je referais
exactement la même chose
oui mais mieux que chaque jour oui c'est
vrai costume c'est moi qui vais signer
bon il n'est pas parfait mais c'est bon
goût mais la semaine ma fille et mon
avis faut bien donner le genre est ce
que tu crois pas que c'est parce que tu
as tu as pas connu ton père que tu as
été tenté de trouver un chez les
extraterrestres
on va dans la psychologie freudienne
fait je pense pas mais tu connais cette
émission maintenant je vais te
dématérialisée il peut faire tout seul
et oui c'est vrai est ce que tu peux te
dématérialisée tout encaisser des
infirmiers et des sages ou est-ce que tu
peux te des matériels absolument fin le
surnaturel n'existe pas il n'y a que
deux naturel scientifique qui n'est pas
encore expliqué non mais je te
dématérialisée mois alors fermés yeux et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard youtube abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu